Lachie une complication Supermercado si
étonnamment pour la postérité Oh Tito dosa
Nouveau Findo rempli quand tu dis listo
a Quichotte détection de co2 notre chargeur une
matière première Kim Basinger kim na pali
Ranma Kim Basinger al-sharia no separe
accros renouvellement centres métalliques sur kaito
shion Phil Masi serrures  écologique donna
kelley blonde cinéma volcanique amérique
comptable famille tartan Evo's a
Machiavel ko2 Cardew table à Santiago
Navi je n'aime pas que les gens regardent ma
femme je suis vraiment entré dans ce projet avec
seulement la pensée qu'elle avait été
victime d'une très petite fille et  elle l'
était, elle n'était qu'une victime et en tant que femme,
elle a dû y faire face
de toute façon, je ne pense pas que je savais que je
devrais apporter toutes les émotions que je pourrais
avoir en moi hors de la
colère, de la rage, je devrais y faire face
blessé d'être la victime non, j'ai adoré, je
devais avoir une haine pour quelque chose et
c'est très difficile pour moi parce que je
ne suis vraiment PAS une personne qui déteste du tout,
allez, qu'est-ce que c'est pour se protéger,
il y a beaucoup de fous là-bas, nous avons
dit  considère un peigne dans l'
actrice qui prévaut as-tu commandé à l'escuela la
beauté un katana pour échapper à une personnalité
Kaposi oh beaucoup donc
MMN reste donc il y a deux femmes
certainement beaucoup de femmes en moi
mais les deux avec lesquelles je me bats sont  une
personne est très timide et très introvertie et
je dois la pousser parce que cela va tellement à l'
encontre du métier et je
dois la laisser derrière moi ou lui parler
pour rester loin de moi, ne viens pas avec moi
aujourd'hui quand le  l'autre doit sortir,
vous savez, surtout dans la musique,
monter sur scène ou faire ce
genre de choses parce que vous devez être
intrépide, vous devez vraiment avoir peur, c'est une
bonne chose, mais avoir vraiment peur,
maintenant laissez le  fille timide éloigne-toi de moi
arrête ne t'en sors pas éloigne-toi de
moi pour que tu saches que je suis avec deux filles ici,
deux femmes, n'est-ce pas